For our experts and emotion interview.
We'll be speaking with Dr Ronald Dahl
on emotion and sleep in adolescents.
Dr Doll is a professor in the school of
Public Health and the director of the
Institute of Human Development at the
University of California Berkeley.
He obtained his MD and fellowship training
in sleep and neuroendocrinology at
the University of Pittsburgh and
completed a pediatric residency at Duke
University at the
University of Pittsburgh.
He led a program of clinical research
at the interface of child psychiatry,
pediatrics and psychology,
focusing on the development of sleep
and arousal as well as aspect regulation
and their relevance to behavioral
and emotional health in children and
adolescents at UC Berkeley.
His current work is now extending these
lines of investigation to bridge from
developmental,
social and aspect of neuroscience to
address a broader range of clinical,
educational and social policy issues
with a primary focus on adolescence.
So I now turn to a very
special experts in emotion,
interviewed together with Dr
Ronald Dahl. So welcome, Ron.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
Thank you.
So I thought we could start with,
uh,
me asking you just a little bit about
what first got you interested in emotion.
I've heard really longstanding
and deep interest in,
in emotion and affective
dimensions of experience broadly.
And I think even going back to
my early training in pediatrics,
the relevance of how feelings influence
real behavior and decision making was
just central. So I think so much of my
experience and trying to target problems.
And then the second thing is that early
on in my research career I was focusing
on emotion disorders.
Uh,
I'm depression anxiety and that raised
a whole set of questions about emotions
and how to think about them and emotion
regulation and that interface nicely
with the sleep and arousal regulation
from a developmental perspective. So it's,
it's sort of a long standing interest
broadly and affective domains and the role
of feelings in the development of young
people and their social experiences.
Excellent.
So I wanna now just ask you
a few questions about your
work in this domain. So,
I mean your work is so exciting and
you're widely known for this work you've
done on the relationship between sleep
and emotion, especially among adolescents.
And I wonder if you could
say just a little bit from
your perspective about what
do you think are the most
exciting discoveries here?
There's really,
there are a couple things I want to
focus initially on this idea of by
directional interactions and the
evidence has been growing. I think we,
there were a lot of hints for that early
on just just from basic observational
studies that emotional arousal can
interfere with sleep and a variety of ways
and emotional distress
can interfere with sleep.
And this idea that sleep
is turning off vigilance.
So anything that raises arousal vigilance
can interact negatively with sleep.
And then the fact that insufficient
sleep or disturbed sleep interferes with
aspects of emotion regulation sets
up this framework for spirals,
negative spirals of
bi-directional interactions
that fits, that spiraled down.
The flip side of that is if
could intervene strategically,
particularly in key windows
and development to scaffold
each of these processes
in positive ways.
It could really alter the trajectory.
And so to me those are the exciting
questions to understand more deeply how
these interactions occur.
The, the, the not just
mechanistically to understand but,
but practically how does this play out in,
in young people's lives,
vulnerabilities and then how insufficient
sleep or emotional disruptions can
start these,
these cycles of interaction in ways
that can be spiraling down or then with
intervention,
a scaffolded to caught up in healthy ways.
So do you think that the spider actual
relationship applies equivalently across
both positively and negatively
balanced emotion states? What's it?
So it's a good question and I think,
um, I have a few compliments about that.
I think first of all,
I think it's an empirical question at the,
at the current state of the science,
I think there's strong evidence for
negative spiraling components for both
aspects of negative emotion
and positive emotions that,
that there's an increased vulnerability
reward sensitivity. In fact,
some of the work I've been
doing with Matt Walker here,
we're trying to pull that
work down into adolescence.
And we beginning to look at that.
And I think that can set off the sort
of risk taking excitement seeking
dimension. And some of this is
relevant to bipolar disorder,
but I think that there's also very
strong evidence for the four aspects of
negative emotion and how insufficient
sleep makes it more difficult to deal
functionally with some
aspect of negative emotion.
But then I also have to say that my
personal bias is that I don't like lumping
emotions into these two categories
as if positive, negative, right.
And I know even the people that
do that understand the nuances,
but increasingly I've been interested
in the idea that the emotion specific
differences in what emotions people
like to feel or don't want to feel or
behaviorally seem to amplify
or avoid can be so different.
And I think that even the,
using the language of what are positive
emotions and what our negative emotions
can obfuscate some really important
questions. And to come back to your,
your initial question,
I think we may be better off served
in understanding how sleep and emotion
specific regulatory processes interact.
And it may be,
there are similarities across any domain
of emotional activation or arousal.
There could be commonalities,
but there also could be specific
types of interactions, for example,
with fear and vigilance or certain kinds
of reward seeking that may not apply to
other emotions even if they're
broadly negative or positive.
So I think these are really important
questions empirically to, to get in and,
and disentangle, uh, in,
in, in more specific ways.
Right. And as you're saying,
it's, it's complex, right?
And there's so many open questions,
right as to how the directional
relationship works with different kinds of
emotional experiences.
And it's an important framework for my,
my approach to these questions is
the idea of looking for windows, uh,
windows, a brain development, windows
of social and emotional development,
where in these patterns of interactions
may set up particular vulnerabilities
for particular youth in
particular environments.
And I think that's another place where
emotions specific or even positive
emotion,
negative emotion,
specific interactions with
sleep could be really important.
You have patterns of learning and
we've been interested, for example,
in the onset of puberty as a time of
fundamental shifts in both sleep and
fundamental shifts, shifts in
some aspects of emotion. Um,
some of it positive emotion,
reward seeking and sensation seeking,
but also sensitivity to social threat
and negative emotions and vigilance.
And I think that that the
emotional learning and the
role of sleep in learning,
um, including emotional learning could
be just as important as whatever,
what the short term effects
are on these systems.
What do you think when you think about
these developmental trajectory is,
to what extent do you think is
relationships bear similarities during
adolescents as compared to
middle or older adulthood?
So I think there are two frameworks
within which I think about these things.
I think in, in many ways there are, uh,
continuity's and this sort of a deep
theme of development that there are
continuity and discontinuity is,
I think in some ways there
are similarities in how
these systems work and how
learning occurs and how regulatory
systems interact in young children,
school aged children, adolescents, adults.
And I think that there's a lot of, um,
value and understanding the commonalities.
I think that in addition to that,
just like any other measure
of growth or development,
there are what I call inflection points.
And I think the important issue about
inflection points in a trajectory is that
there's a relatively larger
impact of learning and experience.
And so one or two or three bad experiences
at a key window of time may have a
bigger impact on the geometry.
And that's the kind of model,
not that it's categorically different,
but there are unique opportunities for
positive early intervention and unique
vulnerabilities that the same
sort of hit or challenge or,
or stress to the system.
And especially if there are a few
of them in a script, you know,
relatively unstable or changing
transition can have a bigger impact.
And so rather than just talk about
a broad group like teenagers,
I think should understand
developmental processes and,
and some of the developmental
process, these are social. Uh,
when you graduated from high school
and Start College or trade school,
you get your first job.
Uh,
but some of them are biologic and puberty
happens to be a biologic transition
that is powerfully impacting a
subset of these neural systems.
And I think that sets up a potential
imbalance because there's new change in
sensitivity. Some of these
neural systems but not others.
And puberty has been happening
earlier and in contemporary society.
And the social challenges of, of young
children in middle school, um, is,
is increasingly complex.
So I think there are opportunities to
understand these inflection points even if
there are similarities to
what happens in older adults,
middle age adults transitioned to old age,
other inflection points.
I think there are reasons to zoom in on
the unique opportunities in these early
witness to develop,
I mean, speaking of this early window
of development and makes me think about,
you know,
this really novel neurodevelopmental
model that you've proposed to try to
understand emotion
regulation in adolescence,
this sort of peak time of discovery
from a scientific perspective.
And I've heard you speak about it as
this time of all gas and no brakes.
And I just wondered if you could say a
little bit about what this expression can
notes in terms of the unique role of
emotion processes during this critical
developmental phase.
So I'm actually glad you asked
that that way because I want to,
I think there's some nuances
to the metaphor and the
variations in the metaphor
that are really important.
And we actually just published a paper
in nature reviews neuroscience, um,
last year when we did a met analysis
and revisited some aspects of this.
So let me zoom in on this idea
of the accelerator and the brake.
I actually think that a better metaphor,
the initial metaphor was starting the
turbocharged engines without a skilled
driver. Um, and then people, and then
Larry Steinberg emphasize the, the, the,
the gas and the brakes. But I think the,
the, the metaphor has limitations. Yes,
there is this capacity for acceleration,
reward seeking sensation seeking that
seems to kick in individual differences.
Some kids still are shy and
cautious when they hit puberty.
But the tendency when
gage novel, exciting, uh,
ambiguous environment seems to increase
at puberty and that can clearly
overwhelmed the capacity to be driving
carefully or putting the brakes on
appropriately.
But I think we shouldn't overstate that
metaphor because when adolescents are
highly motivated to do a complex task,
including a task that requires a lot of
inhibitory control, cognitive control,
tedious tasks like text messaging,
they can, if they're motivated,
they can recruit frontal cortex
pretty effectively. And in fact,
in some situations they
may outperform adults.
And so I think the very ability in the
recruitment of these control systems and
the degree to which they learn this
quickly very so much on social context.
And I think the metaphor is still
relevant because the capacity for these
excitement seeking systems to tip the
balance and overwhelmed, you know,
inhibitory control,
the ability to put on the brakes or
to steer carefully is relevant to
understanding what can happen to really
smart adolescents who can make good
decisions.
But I don't think we should imply they're
incapable of the steering and brakes.
Part of the metaphor they can,
it's just they're vulnerable to zooming
in on the relevance of the social
rewards and that tipping the balance.
And I think that sleep deprivation or
insufficient sleep can amplify that
imbalance.
Uh,
the emotional or the effect of
signals relative to the pausing,
cautiously evaluating for a moment before
acting is probably tipped a bit more.
And I think that's part of the initial
thing we were discussing about the
synergy,
the negative synergy or negative spiral.
It's sleep deprivation on top of someone
who's already a sensation seeking type
of personality in an environment that's
very excitement seeking and has a lot of
risks and then add on to
that staying up really late,
getting up early preschool
and being sleep deprived.
Those can add up for risk factors that
contribute to some of these impulsive
sensation seeking dangerous activities.
So when, this is all really interesting
and I liked the CAG out, you put that,
it's not that they don't have
the capacity for the breaks,
it's just there's contextual factors
and motivational factors that influence
when and how they put on
the brakes. Right? Yeah.
It makes me wonder sort of what unique
treatment implications might this have
for adolescents and managing
their emotions and you know,
thinking about the intervening
role asleep too in that process.
That's a great question.
I,
so I think I'm going to oversimplify
some complex things to sort of zoom in on
my intuitions in this area.
I think one of the principles that's
emerging is that having goals be socially
salient to that individual.
And again,
it's the cart that the heart of and the
art of motivational interviewing, um,
as an approach a of where the techniques
that, that are used with adolescence, uh,
to, to really ground the
motivation for change.
It's something that's relevant and
salient to that individual's own ambiguous
feelings and, and, and,
and, and what's salient.
And having that be socially
salient to adolescents, um,
is a powerful way to activate
these more natural motivations.
Something that's abstract and cognitive
that something could happen to you.
You know,
abstractly,
theoretically in some future time is not
as sanely and it doesn't get into the
aspect of emotional domain and compete
as effectively in the moment and the
charged moment. And so I think
there are two themes to that.
One is having young people do the thinking
and planning early in the process,
anticipating that they're going to get
into a situation with more emotional
charge and not easily be able
to pause and think and reflect.
Um, that's a, that's one part.
And the second thing is to
have the motivation to do that.
Be linked to these emotionally salient,
socially salient goals or,
or, or fears or worries.
I think those anchoring the change,
the reason to change.
So,
so just telling someone to go to bed
earlier so that they can get better grades
or study more or uh,
interact with less irritability within
their relationships could be done in a
way that taps salience for
an individual adolescent.
But it also can be done in
a way that's like, okay,
here's another adult giving me
advice about what I should do.
And when it's 11 o'clock at night and a
friend is texting them about something
exciting that's going on,
it's just not going to compete.
So I think grounding these in ways that
are socially and affectively salient
goals and then helping adolescents,
you know, align their motive,
their own individual motivations, uh, in
those ways are, are important parts of,
of intervention approaches.
Thank you so much.
I mean,
so the last question I wanted to ask you
soak in a little bit about this is just
trying to understand the role of these
different emotional related systems and
that sort of development or etiology
of psychopathology among adolescents in
particular.
And I wonder from your perspective,
what you might consider to be some
of the most important developmental
trajectories here whereby emotion might
play an influence and onset of mood
disorders like depression, some of the
things you've studied in your own work.
So I'm going to,
I'm going to dive into the line of
question that I find most compelling right
now.
Sure.
As relevant to what you asked in terms
of the trajectory to affect disorders.
But I think it's actually relevant to a
broader set of health relevant issues in
adolescence.
And that is that I think affect of science
generally and affective neuroscience
generally,
particularly as it's focused
on adolescence and a and
on these disorders has
focused almost exclusively on
emotions and emotion regulation.
And I think the effect of
dimension of motivation,
it's relatively understudied.
And what I mean by that is there's
aspects of motivation that are,
that are linked to goals
and and cognitive processes.
But a key part of motivation
is the feeling of desire,
the feeling of value,
the fast automatic processing that
something has salients and motivational
learning in this aspect of domain is
I think part of the window of unique
opportunity in adolescence.
I think the brain expects new motivational
learning to occur about what really
is salient to your goals as an individual.
You becoming an individual and a complex
society and the feeling of what has
meaning purpose, value, uh,
connects to your passions.
Um, these are key windows of
learning that create fast,
automatic prioritizations about motivate.
Not that you make yourself do
something you don't want to do,
but falling in love with literature
or dance or changing the world or,
or a particular activity that becomes so
strong, you don't make yourself do it.
Someone would have to prevent
you from doing it because you,
you've in essence fallen in love
with a particular kind of activity.
And that's sort of the
extreme end of this spectrum.
But I think there's a dimension
of motivational learning
that I think extremely
important. Depression is a
bit of a paradox in many ways.
What happens with depression is a
loss of certain kinds of motivation,
especially this aspect of dimension.
This,
this pull towards social
rewards and pointing engagement.
They can make themselves
do it, uh, to some degree,
but it's not as naturally motivated.
And I think this inflection points where
some motivations can fiercely attached
to very unhealthy things like
drugs and alcohol risk taking, uh,
sensation seeking,
um,
some can really disengage loose
motivation as another inflection point.
And then finally healthy
versions of these passions,
a mastery curve of channeling your,
your goals and these feelings
of motivation in ways
that are really leading to
productive engagement. And I'm over
simplifying some very complex issues,
but I think justice affect of neuroscience
has brought a new way of thinking
about emotions and emotion regulation.
I think there's exciting opportunities
to understand motivation and motivational
learning and the role of feelings and
motivations and particularly in this
interval of adolescence.
I mean that's just really wonderful and
really interesting and it makes me think,
you know, you've illuminated a lot
of complex issues in this field.
Where do you see the
future of this work headed?
What are some of the most
critical next steps? So
I'm going to,
I'm going to focus a bit in my,
in and these comments on process and
having worked in this area for more years
than I want to admit at this point.
Um,
I think the most important issue
is creating teams of people,
teams of researchers who
can tackle the complexity,
especially developmentally.
These are really complicated issues.
If you try to reduce emotion or motivation
too narrowly to a laboratory task or
an imaging study or controlled experiment
or if you just sample in ways you can
look in natural environments and really
ecologically valid ways to do cross
sectional studies versus Longitudinal
to really understand the nuances of the
social dimension, the
affect dimension, uh,
peer interactions and emotions really
requires teams of people who can slice
through the complexity with
well the science studies
sample appropriately in the
diversity of things that
can influence these issues.
Think about the context as you mentioned,
how important context is for activating
different kinds of emotions and
motivations and follow them longitudinally
to understand development trajectory.
No one or two labs can do those things
well and so I think one of the challenges
in,
especially for young people who are told
they've got a super specialized in one
area and become experts. Yeah,
it's how to do team science,
how to learn to be having pockets
of expertise but engage in these
interdisciplinary,
transdisciplinary teams that I think are
really going to tackle the next level
of integration and work
across these levels.
Especially for things as complicated
as emotion and motivation.
So related then,
what kind advice would you give students
who are just thinking about embarking
in this field?
So it's hard to get,
I mean I think it,
it can be quite different for
different kinds of students,
but I think the idea of balancing that,
that the Yin Yang of on one hand,
zooming in and getting expertise and
developing the specialization that's
required to do science well.
But I think other head balancing
that with breadth and, and,
and having co mentors or,
or we're spending some time with
interdisciplinary teams because I think
increasingly the high impact socially
and clinically relevant questions are
going to require these teams.
And if people spend all of the
formative years and their development
professionally, um, you know,
doing individualized work,
they're not going to develop the skills
and ways of thinking to really integrate
and do these,
these collaborative that not everybody
could do collaborative work and,
and we still need the,
the industry,
the brilliant individual who really
pushes knowledge forward in their niche.
But I also think we need more young
scientists who are going to do these cross
disciplinary,
um,
approaches and integrate and really
creative ways across these stickers
levels. Well, thank you so
much for speaking today.
It was really wonderful to
hear your insights in this
field and realize just how
complex the issues are and how much do
we need these interdisciplinary teams to
move these important questions forward.
Well,
thank you.
I really enjoyed it and I look forward
to hearing other people in the series
comments, uh, on these really interesting
issues and, and um, and it's an exciting,
I think the other thing I wanna say,
it's such an exciting time in this field.
It's, there's so much new
knowledge and opportunity,
so the more young bright people we can
get into the field thinking about these
things and helping us
understand them the better.
Right. So, thank you so much.
So this concludes our experts in emotion
interview with Doctor Ron Dahl from the
University of California at Berkeley.
Thanks again.